i'll miss harry's world so much
welcome back to another video fellow
potterheads the harry potter cast has
spoken many times about how spectacular
the 10 years on set of the franchise was
for them
but did you know that a lot of these
actors were so close to not landing the
role
the majority of the cast don't have your
traditional audition story
and you'll never believe how some of
these actors landed a part in the film
ready to hear the stories accio year
2000
ten-year-old daniel had no idea how much
the harry potter producers wanted him
for this role
his dad actually knew some of the
filmmakers from having worked with them
in his everyday job as a literary agent
that didn't stop them from rejecting
their offers to have daniel audition
though
in the early days harry potter was
actually supposed to be filmed in
america
and the actors were asked to sign on for
all movies at just 10 years old
you know you would sign up for the
entire series and
it was all to be filmed in america dan's
parents thought that that was a little
too disruptive to their son's life
little did they know what would happen
but then one trip to the theater turned
that all around
daniel's parents took seeing the harry
potter screenwriters as a sign
and voila i don't believe in fate but
very fortunately my parents do
he went on to audition and found out he
got the part while taking a bath
to this day dan claims it was luck and
the fact that he loved what he was doing
that landed him the part
dragon egg uh-huh is that what it is
yeah
rupert's audition story is a true
testament to how similar he actually is
to ron weasley
he sent not one but two audition tapes
he never received a response from the
first one
so decided to make another one and take
it to the next level with
a wrap i thought i did a wrap how i
wanted to pay rome
that got the casting department's
attention and after multiple auditions
he was officially ron weasley something
doesn't make sense
back in 2011 he even performed the wrap
take a listen
hello there my name is rupert
i hope you like this and don't think i
stink emma watson had close to no
experience when she was cast in harry
potter
the casting directors from the film had
visited schools in london looking for
the perfect hermione
my school got an invitation to like get
16 of us from the school of the ages
around
11. they obviously loved her because
they called her in for a proper audition
six more to be exact and then finally
offered her the part
emma still believes that she got the
role because of her determination
even without experience how hermione of
her
jk rowling thought so too even if she
originally mentioned that emma was a
little
too pretty to play hermione shut up if
phil just comes around the corner any
second now
the theme of matthew lewis's neville
audition is 100
dedication he waited in line for about
five hours with his mom at an open
audition just for the chance to show his
talent
he was a huge fan of harry potter and
needed a role
just been so so fortunate to be in a
project like that but a huge fan of the
books
even after his mom tried convincing him
just to head home
he was determined to reach the front of
the line and he did
believe it or not tom felton wasn't in
the market to play draco malfoy
he originally auditioned for both harry
potter and ron weasley
he obviously didn't get those lead roles
but we're pretty sure
him playing draco instead was the
perfect decision and tom thinks he knows
the exact point where they knew he'd be
a great malfoy
he spent the entire audition pretending
like he was a fan of the books
so when the producers asked him what his
favorite scene was he had no choice but
to lie
the guy next to me said something about
gringotts and goblins i was just like
yeah
the producers must have taken that as a
very draco thing to do
and he got the part ivana lynch being in
the harry potter franchise was fate
and you can't convince us otherwise
before she even auditioned for the role
she had been pen pals with jk rowling
who encouraged her to overcome her
eating disorder
so when she heard there would be an open
audition for luna in london
she flew over with her father and waited
hours with thousands of other girls
after being screened on her looks take a
listen to what she told casting agents
and i was like if you don't pick me
that's okay that's your choice but
you're gonna be wrong
when they called in the actual casting
director to come in during her audition
she knew things had gone well and she
was right
just three days later they called her
back for a second audition
the rest is history we became well pen
friends
before i got the role bonnie wright has
her brother to thank for landing the
role of ginny weasley
she had only been nine years old at the
time of the harry potter casting
and her older brother was a huge fan of
the series so when he mentioned to her
that she looked like jenny she decided
to read the books and absolutely
fell in love after begging her mother to
get her an audition for jenny she got
the role
and here we are almost two decades later
i mean i started when i was nine i think
i don't know i think you can still
vividly remember
quite a lot of it james and oliver also
attended an open audition together
and continued to get called back until
landing the role but the funny thing was
they had no idea who was playing which
weasley twin
so they got to set the first day still
not knowing
and after getting their scripts they
finally decided it was time to ask the
casting director
except she had no idea either she
eventually came back with an answer
but james and oliver are convinced they
decided who would play who on a whim
tom felton wasn't the only one who had
no idea what or who
harry potter was devin murray's harry
potter audition had a pretty
embarrassing twist to it
after being invited to a screen test for
the first film he walked straight past
daniel to director chris columbus and
said
hi harry nice to meet you we're pretty
sure chris laughed it off considering he
was later offered the part
not to be dramatic but it would probably
be a crime against humanity if helena
bottom carter wasn't bellatrix
but that was almost a reality did my
research because i just thought
dude i didn't quite extend as far as
reading all the books
she wasn't the original actress cast for
the role they originally brought on
helen mcrory
but helen left the role after she found
out she was pregnant and they brought on
helena
the two ended up playing sisters helen
mcrory was recast as narcissa malfoy in
the last three films
the original dumbledore was played by
the iconic richard harris before he
sadly passed
away but we were so close to never
seeing his version of dumbledore
the producers offered him the role
multiple times and each time
offered him more money but richard just
didn't want to spend his golden years
working on a franchise
but he eventually gave in for that we
have his granddaughter to thank
who hilariously told her grandfather
she'd never speak to him again if he
didn't take on the role
alan rickman wasn't the first choice for
snape let that sink in
allen was only brought on after tim roth
turned down the role to take on the
blockbuster hit
planet of the apes at least it worked
out for both of them
we have to say we're very glad they
decided to go the route of alan rickman
just look at how much he loved the
franchise
i won't really miss anything because
it's been such an extraordinarily
complete
character to play rae finds originally
thought that voldemort just
wasn't his cup of tea he was a
classically trained actor
and couldn't see himself playing the
character but his sister talked some
sense into him
and we got the dark masterpiece that is
voldemort
honestly his theater training made
voldemort that much more dramatic
and we love it being the author of the
series
jk rowling of course had some names
swirling around her mind when it came to
casting
and robbie coltrane was one of them she
hand-picked him for the role of hagrid
and said he was the perfect choice
how could anyone argue with that luckily
he agreed and
absolutely loved his experience working
on the films
i think it's great it's it's a great
feeling gary oldman may have been the
perfect serious black
but his original motive behind getting
the role wasn't because he loved the
franchise
he simply needed the money to support
his family i needed the work
that's the honest answer honestly
respect
after getting the role and filming
prisoner of azkaban he fell in love with
the series alongside his kids
it's hard to believe that we were this
close from getting an entirely different
harry potter cast
it makes us even more glad that our fave
actors got the parts
even if they were in very unconventional
ways
what audition story is your favorite
let's chat about it below
we'd love it if you hit that subscribe
button and give this video a thumbs up
see you later potterheads